ولكن من مصر نبدا حيث الكثافه السكانيه
الاكبر في المنطقه العربيه
فوصلت اعداد مصر الى 104 مليون نسمه في
اكتوبر مقارنه ب130 فبراير الماضي بزياده
تبلغ مليون نسمه في سبعه اشهر
[موسيقى]
الزياده السكانيه كانت وما زالت اكبر
المشاكل التي تواجهها الحكومات المصريه
المتعاقبه وتعتبر اكبر المعوقات لعجله
التنميه لما لها من اثار الاقتصاديه
واجتماعيه كبيره على المجتمع منها البطاله
وزياده الاستهلاك وانخفاض نصيب الفرد من
الموارد الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]
اسباب عديده وراء هذه الزياده المستمره
وخاصه في الريف والاحياء الشعبيه منها
الزواج المبكر تفضيل الذكور عن الاناث في
بعض المجتمعات ووجود معتقدات الراسخه لدى
الاسر ان كثره الانجاب يعتبر عزوه وسند
[موسيقى]
ولمواجهه هذه الظاهره تضع الحكومه المصريه
مبادرات وبرامج القوميه لزياده الوعي
باهميه تنظيم الاسره ونشر عيادات وقوافل
طبيه في جميع القرى والمحافظات لتقديم
الرعايه الصحيه للامهات وتوفير وسائل
تنظيم الاسره مجانا بتكلفه وصلت الى 100
مليون جنيه مصري سنوات
[موسيقى]
وقد اشار رئيس المصري في اكثر من لقاء عن
خطوره الزياده السكانيه في تعطيل حركه
التنميه سمر بشكل صباح العربيه من القاهره